Okay. Now what I'd like
to do is something, uh,
that you'll probably cut out
because of copyright issues,
but it's a kind of fun warm up.
Anyway,
so we're going to go ahead and do
this and then we'll actually start,
I got about a one minute warm up here,
ladies and gentlemen, and we've got Linda.
Paul is like a Vegas show act.
Okay.
She's going to warm us up and we're going
to get up and we're going to get into
it here,
right off the bat in our exploration
of Dupal and triple meter.
So here we go.
Linda Paul.
All right,
everybody standing.
It'll be worth it
for the DUPLO meter.
You have the parked to the
side. It's okay. Pick a march,
which put, gets the downbeat right
or left. Okay. Sorry. Didn't know.
Yeah,
you can do this on your test too.
10 Julene trees.
Marmalades guy
because you sick white.
Slowly got it.
Go.
Wow.
Okay.
We got that
bridge.
No,
from the ridiculous to the,
we're going to go to our first slide
and that takes us to the question of sale.
We,
we hadn't never really nailed this down.
I don't think when an instrument,
any instrument,
the piano plays a note.
What you hear is one fundamental pitch.
You are also hearing very
small amounts of other pitches.
Usually these get charted out into
the so called overtones 32 partials or
overtones.
And you can see them playing out here.
The amount of force in each of those
partials we'll call it the amplitude of
each of the partials varies according
to the acoustical properties of a
particular instrument so that each of
these peaks here represents a particular
partial.
But you can see that they do not
decline in any kind of straight decline.
Some of them bump up from time
to time more, um, uh, push.
They're more volume there.
So when we hear any particular sound,
again we're hearing an amalgam of
many sounds and the particular,
the importance of each of these partials
in the aggregate of sound is what gives
it its particular color.
If you've ever worked with a synthesizer,
I think in very simple terms here,
what an electronic synthesizer
does is to his play with these.
They can push down the seventh partial,
they can bring up the ninth partial,
they can push down the 13th partial and
bring up the 15th and thereby change the
sound of the clarinet into a French horn.
They play with these partials
on each of these notes,
but this is just one sound with all
of these other things mixed in to uh,
the, the Midland that produces the quality
or Tambour of a particular instrument.
Okay,
that's that point.
Now we're going to go on and review
a few things that we talked about.
Last lecture.
Remember we were talking about beat,
which is this sort of regular pulse,
the pulse of life,
the pulse of music that
comes at regular intervals.
We were talking about the subdivision of
that Paul Paul's the kind of organizing
of that pulse in two meters and that we
had this capacity to indicate what the
meter was by these numbers.
Two, four and three,
four for Dupo and triple meter.
Remember we were demonstrating
listening to the Ravel Bolero there,
we had rhythms super imposed.
We had two prominent rhythms up above.
The rhythm is simply these patterns
usually repeating patterns of longs and
shore that get super imposed,
as I say,
are set up above the
basic beat underneath.
We also learn from the Ravel's Bolero
that nobody actually plays the beat.
That's too basic,
but our mind hearing all of these complex
rhythms extrapolates the beat from
this complexity. Okay. That
by way of a quick review. Now,
two other terms that we have touched on.
What's tempo in music?
What's tempo in music? Yes. Gentlemen,
the pace or speed of the of the piece,
particularly the beat, the beat
will, will do control that.
So it's the pace or speed of
the beep. Thanks very much. Uh,
we can take a particular here
I'm conducting three one, two,
three, one, two, three, one, two,
three, one, two, three, one, two, three.
Obviously I'm accelerating there.
We use the fancy Italian term at cello.
Rondo for that, we could be going
with a very fast tempo. Three one,
two, three, one, two, three,
one, two, three and slow it down.
Obviously we would be retarding the
music Ritardando or a retard at that
particular point. All right.
With that. By way of background,
let's go on to to what we might call
rhythmic devices here to rhythmic devices.
The first is syncopation.
We worked a little bit with
this last time for syncopation.
Let's go to the board over here.
If we have a particular rhythm and this
is a rhythm and hear the beats in the
meter underneath, we would
be coming along. One, two,
one, two. Uh, okay.
Obviously this is the bar of syncopation.
We did this in section last week,
but you can see that this
node is the syncopated note.
It's jumping into early.
We expect it to sound there.
So what sick a patient is,
is simply a,
the insertion of an impulse,
a, uh, a hit, if you will, uh,
at a metrical place that
we do not expect it to be.
Usually the metrical impulses on the beat.
With syncopation,
the impulse can come suddenly off the
beat comes suddenly off the beat and it
kind of gives it a little snapper
jet we jazzy aspect to, uh,
to the music. We talked about
that in the Cole Porter last time.
Here's what I remember
a couple of years ago,
there's a clothing store called Tj Maxx,
Tj Maxx.
They had this little jingle
out there yet at that, that,
that, that, that, that, that,
that just a little bit,
and this then you were
supposed to say Tj Maxx,
I'll remember Tj Maxx forever because
of this guy's little syncopation.
It's in there.
We really remember these musical,
think about back in your childhood,
your nursery rhymes and capacity,
oral material to be retained.
Okay. Death Dot. Duh.
Here's beat to it jumps into early.
This actually I think the
from the Greek Word Cinco,
batch y n k o p e Cinco pay, is
that how you pronounce it? Uh,
but it means to kind of cut short,
to cut short and therefore
get Ian a little bit earlier.
Now the master of syncopation of
course in music was Scott Joplin,
African American composer writing,
uh,
a lot around the area of St Louis in
the turn of the 20th century. You know,
his music from pieces
such as the entertainer.
So let's play just a little bit of the
entertainer very slowly. Um, and I,
my question to you is,
where's the syncopation?
Is it in the left hand of the piano
or in the right hand of the piano?
Is it in the base or the melody?
Where's the sake of patient lefthand?
Right. Right. Base is just going, well,
what is the base going
in that fashion?
One is playing eith those one
and two and subdivided the beef.
Where's the syncopation?
It's their Yachty, the,
the, the, the and so on.
So you're tapping your foot,
you're tapping the beat and a lot
of the music is coming off the beat.
Let's see if we can do that.
Let's see if we can create our
own syncopated orchestra here.
We've got an example up here.
This is the conception of it.
Let's see if we can actually execute it.
What I'd like you to do,
everybody tap your foot.
We're going to do this in forge just
for just because I think it works out
better. So everybody tap your foot
with a four beat. Here we go. One, two,
three, four, one, two, three,
four. I'm nice and loud and on.
I want to hear it. Okay. Now take
your hand on a chair, your notebook,
your computer or whatever,
and do sink a patient off of
that according to this pattern.
One, two, ready, go.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, Tom.
Okay, good. I see Daniel down
here. He's got this nail. Okay. Um,
so that's what I think a patient is and
it isn't much more difficult than that.
The second rhythmic device that we have
to be aware of the music we frequently
encounter is this concept of the triplet.
Now, most music that we listened to,
and here's a good example
because it, uh, uh,
it plays it out so clearly in the melody.
Most music that we listened to
a takes the beat one, two, one,
two and subdivides it into two one
and two. And musicians like this,
an visit one and two and one and two.
And so each quarter note
has two eighth notes.
We could also take the two ways
notes and divide them into two uh,
16th notes. And then we get oh, one
and a two and a one and a two. I,
or something,
something like that.
Hmm.
Yeah. That, that, that, that, that,
that, that, that, but of course, most,
most music,
although it operates that way,
not all music continues in that
fashion. Oftentimes. Occasionally.
Can you hear off the time
somewhere between the two,
the beat is divided into three. So what
I've got here is an example of that.
It's actually what we call my country.
Tis of Thee, I think. Montana,
the Dotcom, palm, Palm, palm, Palm, Palm.
So that's it. I think it's been set by
a number of composers over the years.
Beethoven said it, uh,
under the heading of God.
Save the King George the
third or somebody, uh,
no problem. George third,
probably dead by then. Um,
who was King of England?
Uh, let's say an 18, 10.
Who knows that answer? I don't know.
George. The third would have been dead.
A. Okay. So in any event, we're
coming along toward the end of it.
Oh.
So you can hear ya'll Tathata PARP arm,
the triplet being inserted.
So a triplet is simply insertion
of three notes in the place of two.
Not more complicated than that. A,
here's what we expect what that De,
but we get di Di di, di, di, di, di, di,
di yet at decrepit.
The interesting thing here is that
the base continues along with the DUPO
pattern.
The Bass is going
where the upper voice has.
Beethoven could have made
that base go with triplets.
Two actually it's all set up for it.
Both melody in base could
have had the triplet,
but he chose to have the DUPO and
the base, the triple up above.
Let's see if we can do that.
It's a little bit of a
challenge for the performance.
Let's see if you can tap your
left hand to a Dupo pattern. One,
two,
one,
two and then take your right hand and
do a triplet against it in the triple a
pattern. One, two, ready, go.
Yeah. Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
one to two. It's harder
in your thing, right?
But that's the kind of
thing that musicians,
particularly a percussion players
have to be able to execute.
All right now, um, and
insertion sort of discourses.
We're going to talk a little bit about
musical texture, musical texture.
This is discussed in your,
in your textbook in example.
In example, are chapter
six in chapter six, uh,
texture and music is the
dispositions of the musical lines.
I was trying to think this morning of an
analogy and I thought I came up with a
good one.
It has to do with tapestries and carpets
and things like that where you weave
different strands in in different ways
and somewhere in my deep recesses I have
these, these were words, web and warp or
something like that. Does that make any,
does that have any resonance
to, you know, all right.
I think it's out there in weaving.
I got to dig it out.
I tried to find it on Google
really quick and nothing came up,
but I think there's this idea of how
you organize a tapestry in that fashion.
In any event,
in music,
we have different strands and these
trends can be organized in different ways.
We simplified by saying this,
that there are saying that there
are three fundamental textures,
monophonic texture,
homophonic texture and polyphonic texture.
And to exemplify this one day.
The curve to me.
Well why not take a tune that everybody
knows amazing grace and sort of said it
in different ways to exemplify
these three textures.
So that's what we've got on the sheet for
today. Everybody's got the sheet there.
And what I would like to do is
just have every one, all of this.
We'll just seeing law here.
We won't sing.
The tech will just sing amazing grace.
And what kind of started at pitch
dog? Hey, pretty good today. Okay,
so,
so we'll start it at pitch there and
I'll give you two and then we'll sing law
and we will exemplify monophonic texture.
Here we go.
One sing
la La la La la La la,
la La.
Okay.
That's all we have to do.
You don't have to read the notes cause
you've got the, the sound in your ears,
part of your oral memory.
So that's monophonic texture.
Just one pitch actually. Was it just
one pitch? What do you think about that?
How many pitches? Let's do this
again. We'll sing it again.
How many actual frequencies are
we generating here? One sick,
la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la La.
So how many pitches are we generating
really to the gentlemen are
singing and one off. Do you have,
we're singing below middle c
and the ladies are singing.
Yeah,
but that's still a monophonic texture.
They'll, those notes have the same names.
W W we were going day gea show.
As long as the notes have the same
names where it sounds the same,
even though there may be
Optiv doubling in there,
we still think of that as monophonic
texture. Linda, come on up.
We're going to exemplify
homophonic texture here. Um, and,
and we want you to sing the melody and
we'll try to do the parts underneath it.
It homophonic texture is where
it all lines up pretty together.
All the parts are changing together.
One,
sin,
La, la, la, la,
la. Ah, ah,
ah.
One more time. We need it. We're
going to get our third ready.
Safe.
Ah,
yeah.
how sweet it is.
Okay.
So that's how sweet sounding homophonic
texture mostly just course. Thanks Linda.
Um, then we can take this and turn
it into something a lot more complex.
We'll sing a lot of lines going their
own way. This we call polyphony.
We also used the word counterpoint,
sort of synonymous with it.
So part three down there at the bottom,
we've got an example of polyphony where
I've taken the tune and sort of set it
against itself a little bit.
Yeah.
MMM.
So it's just a lot more complex.
A lot of independent lines going on up
above take of one line sync of a group of
lines. Here's one sound,
here's a group of sound.
Different pitches in it.
Actually three different pitches near
as opposed to just one pitch, one pitch,
three pitches or three or four pitches.
Moving at different in different ways.
Kind of independent [inaudible].
So that's a different thing.
I'm a monophonic homophonic
in polyphonic texture.
Now we're going to turn focus here just
a bit more on polyphonic texture because
there are two types of polyphonic texture.
Uh,
the first we'll call imitative polyphonic
texture. And here in amazing grace,
we really do have imitative polyphonic
texture because you, as you can see,
we have in the base there Inbar to
the base imitating the upper right.
Pardon?
And then toward the end there in bar 13.
Okay.
The base,
and I've added an extra note, it occurred
to me, hey, I could take that theme in,
term it up by side down against
itself and it would work.
So that's called musical inversion.
Bock bock would like that he likes,
he's kind of mind games with,
with music. So it's complex stuff.
This polyphony work,
this counterpoint.
So this is imitative counterpoint because
there's one idea that keeps back and
back.
Now there's another kind of counterpoint
called free counterpoint where it's
highly independent
lines, uh, are sounding,
but they're not imitating one or another.
Let's listen to just a section of this.
We should have this,
it's Louis Armstrong and we'll talk
more about Louis Armstrong as we proceed
here.
So listen to a good example of,
of non imitative texture.
Polyphonic texture.
Pretty cool stuff, Huh? Where
was Louis Armstrong from?
Chicago actually did recordings in
Chicago, but he wasn't from Chicago.
Where's the heart and soul and jazz
in America? New Orleans, right? Yeah.
That's why it's so important culturally
for the history of the United States.
So what we want to do now is to begin
to think about counting measures,
counting majors, accounting majors. Uh,
and we're going to do this by
staying with this piece of,
of Louis Armstrong here.
And we need to be able to count measures
so that we can figure out the syntax of
music. Music is a language and it is
made up of his same syntax and syntax,
you know, consists of phrases and the
order in which those phrases occur.
But maybe even before we can
recognize the syntax of music,
we have to figure out what a phrase is.
So to do that,
we've got to be able to count measures.
How do we do this? Well, musicians,
again, have developed a following
sort of process, let's say.
Oftentimes orchestral musicians, they're
sitting there and they're not playing,
so they have to be able to
count for a long period of time.
So it'd be going along in this fashion.
Let's say it's Dupal one to two,
to three to four,
two,
they're just adding introduced as
on each down. It's a very simple,
simple idea. Oops, I may have
hit the wrong button here. Um,
so that's what we're going to do.
Think of these poor French horn
players in the orchestra. They have,
they play so rarely, and then it's
so important when they do play,
they'd be out there 78 to 79 to 82 81,
two.
You've got to count forever.
We won't have to count quite that long,
but even before we can't, we've got to
figure out what the meter of the music is.
So let's start with that.
Now. What's the, uh,
let's go back or I guess we're
going to go to the beginning.
What's the meter of this piece? And then
we'll go ahead and count some measures.
Got that.
So it's Dupal meter.
Our brains got all that stuff coming in
there and we're probably focusing a lot
on amazing. Boom. Both the
Tuba that's playing there.
So let's go on now we're going to
hear Louis Armstrong himself. Play.
What instrument did Louis Armstrong play?
Trumpet.
And he had this wonderful rich
sound, but boy it was, it was a big,
huge sound. Kind of the ultimate
in your face trumpet player.
So we're going to hear a solo by Louis
Armstrong now and let's count along.
Once the phrase begins, I'll get you
started and then you count the measures.
Here we go.
Let's start it again. I didn't,
it started writing where? Uh,
right where the phrase being, here
we go. Ready? But that's not, no,
they're just to just go back where
you were. That's fine. That's great.
Go ahead.
And then he disappeared.
So how many bars did you count there?
How long was the phrase that be
Armstrong play eight measures.
Everybody agree with that?
Anybody stay?
Seven better say eight in music
asymmetry is not the norm in music.
So eight to eight is a good bet there.
Let's go back in here. Another solo.
So wonderful clarinet solo by, by someone
named Johnny Dobbs. Long dead of course.
But one of the most beautiful,
beautiful,
incredible clarinet solo you'll ever
want to hear. How long is this a solo?
How long has this phrase
here by Johnny Dobbs?
Here we go.
1616. So twice as long. But that,
that, that's, that's sort of good news.
A lot of music is made up of these two,
four and four for sorts of aggregates.
Uh,
and then we'll just go on to listen
to the end of this where every in,
it's hard to know again what the
melody is or what the phrase is here.
It's just everybody playing.
Remember, are they using music here?
Could these gentlemen read music?
It's not clear that this
particular group could, it's all,
I'm sure Lou Lou yarn trail
would read some music, but again,
we're just getting away of what he's
doing. All of this was was orally,
orally transmitted in orally taught.
So let's listen to the end of,
it's called willy the weeper.
You're going to have it as one
of your listening exercises.
Let's listen to the end of it here.
Yeah. Okay. Here we go with, okay.
In high school band here,
what do you call that at the end?
You still call it that Stinger.
The end sort of a syncopated
bounce at the end of the day.
How long was that particular phrase?
16 bars there again,
and they are perfect example of free
counterpoint. You've got the trombone,
the clarinet.
The Trump,
but they're all just doing their own
thing in the context of the harmonies that
are playing out here. And it's just,
it's just magical. Just magical.
I think we're happy music,
right?
How could you possibly be sad when
listening to that kind of music and they
played this kind of music coming
back from funerals, you know,
you're dancing into heaven
is that kind of thing. Yeah,
I bet there's heavenly music
of that short. Uh, okay.
Now let's go onto another thing that
we'll want to be doing here and that I
guess he is, um, taking a little
bit of rhythmic dictation,
writing down some simple, some simple
rhythms. How are we going to do this?
Why do we want to do this?
Because we want to remember things.
Volk Gong.
Amadeus Mozart had a
very good musical memory.
There are lots of stories about
Mozart's musical memory. In 1778,
he was in the town of Manheim.
He heard a string quartet
by a man named convening.
It was never published
or no recordings of it.
Mozart goes to Paris about six months
later. He bumps into Cam beanie. He said,
Oh yeah, it can be any. I remember you,
I heard your string quartet in Monheim
and he sits down at the piano and plays
this thing. You know, he didn't have,
actually, he wasn't studying this thing.
It wasn't trying to memorize it.
He heard it just once.
Six months later he could remember
will movement of a string quartet.
Another famous story in 1770,
he goes into Rome,
into the Sistine Chapel. It's
holy week. He goes to hear the,
the well known Misa Ray ray of, of, of uh,
lay Greg Gregorio Alegra.
Uh,
you're not supposed to copy this
piece because it's supposed to be only
performed in the Sistine Chapel.
Mozart in goes in, he hears it.
He and his father walked back to
the end where they are staying.
He writes down this four to five minute
composition note for note and just one
city. That's pretty scary,
wouldn't it be, I mean,
just off on a different planet in terms
of your capacity to process or old
material. But we, I can't do
that. I couldn't begin to do
that. How much can I hear?
Two seconds, three seconds, four
seconds. I could probably remember that.
And he's hearing multiple
parts, not just melody. Uh,
so we have to come up,
we mortals have to come up with some
other device and our device to remember
things just to try to write it down.
Because my premise here is
if you can write music down,
clearly you are hearing
it clearly and you,
you would have a better chance of
remembering it if you could write it down.
So it, it just helps us focus
on these isolated events.
We're not going to try to remember
everything in music too complex.
We're going to focus on the simple
salient things. It could be an instrument,
could be an important rhythm.
So let's listen to some more
music of Mussorgsky here.
Modesta Mussorgsky we had that
very interesting piece last time.
Polish ox cart where he used
this principle of low sounds,
produce, uh, some, uh, sound
waves that stay forever.
And we hear those low
sounds first and last.
So here we're going to hear another piece
from that pictures at an exhibition.
It's called great gate of Kiev.
So let's listen to a little of this,
17 or 1874 I believe,
or 1870 surely.
And let's listen to a bit of it and then
we're going to focus just on the rhythm
start can die.
Interesting. There are two
possible explanations to to this.
Some of you are going with
a very slow tempo. One, two,
one, two others are a bit
uncomfortable. That Dee Dee, Dee Dee,
you're going twice as fast, which
is correct. Well, for our purposes,
both are correct and we'll know how to
figure this out on test. If you say, ah,
you've got two measures here and you're
writing particular symbols will know
that you heard with this, with
the slower possibility, uh,
if you've got four measures
and different symbols,
you're clearly subdividing the beat,
but hearing that as the beat. So,
so all I'm really interested
in here is the idea that,
that we have a Dupal meter.
Having said that,
let's assume that we do have
the slower tempo here. One,
uh,
let me play a little bit at the piano.
Jimmy, be moving rather
slowly. Let's all sing it.
La,
la,
la, la, la. La La.
Okay. So that's the music.
Now having done this setup,
if you think about it and think about
the fact that what note symbol gets the
beat in our course quarter note.
Okay.
Um,
so every gesture of the hand is going
to be the equivalent of a quarter note.
What's going to be my first note symbol?
MMM,
yeah,
yeah. I have no, here's one
gesture. Here's another gesture.
MMM.
Okay. So I've got you going there. You
take your piece of paper. Now if you,
if you want to hum the piece just quietly
to yourself, that's fine. That's good.
If I hear lots of buzzing out there,
that means you're into it. So a home,
the piece a little bit to
yourself and with George Skis.
Great Gate of Kiev here and pictures of
exhibition and see if you can write down
those particular symbols.
Okay.
Okay, let's sing it again.
Here we go. Ready Go.
La La,
la La la,
la La.
Let's focus
la La la
just on that unit that measure
la La la.
Having trouble with this.
Look at this.
La La la one gesture to notes,
two pitchers law.
What should those,
what should the rhythmic value
of those two pitches? Bee Larva.
Yeah,
too.
And within one beat would
give us eighth notes. Okay.
So let's finish it off one more
time. He'll be ready. Go. Okay.
La, la, la, la,
la,
la La.
So what should we write up here? I lost
my black marker, but that doesn't matter.
Okay.
La La
la, which I right now,
well those are the two A's.
And as we were talking about La La,
then what?
La La
one note for each gesture.
And we've just done a rhythmic dictation
of the beginning of Mussorgsky's great
gate of Kiev from
pictures at an exhibition.
So you're not going to forget the this
particular melody and it's because it
sounds so grand.
There's another reason we're not going
to forget it if you focused on it in that
way. So when we later on we're dealing
with symphonies and things like that,
you'd may be sketching
little motivity can snippets,
little rhythmic snippets that
you'll file away. All right,
let's listen a little bit
more to the missorts skeet.
And then we're going to go on just
a bit more to the next excerpt.
And here's my question for you.
You're going to hear the violins
play a running scale. Yachty,
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee
Dee Dee Dee, if our beat is this. Yeah.
T t t t t. T. T. T. T. T. T. T.
What note values are in music of the
violinists at this particular moment?
You don't even have to see the score.
You can figure it out.
Yeah.
So what, what, what no value
are they playing their 16th?
Because we've got four impulses.
Dizzy yet. T t, t, t, t.
T for each beat.
Let's go on to the next here.
Now a couple of questions we could ask.
The theme comes back.
We're going to listen to it again.
What string technique of the violins
using at this particular moment and,
and then, uh, what rhythmic
device does the trumpet in Church.
So let's focus on the streams first.
We may hear this twice. Go ahead Linda.
[inaudible]
okay. To, what are they doing
there? What are they playing there?
Tremolo just kind of Filler,
right when we need a big sound here.
Let's get the violins to kind of
fill in sonic space. It's kind of,
it must be something in cooking like that.
Use cornstarch or something. A filler,
I don't know. Just to make,
give them something body.
So this is kind of giving
the music body here.
It's no not particular
interest melodically. Now
when the trumpet interest,
something of interest happens, what?
Rhythmic devices. The trumpet ensured him.
So let's go back to the same spot. Well
here the Tremolo and then the trumpet.
Here we go. Notice that the tempo
is slowed down a bit here also.
Yeah,
same,
same passage.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we'll phase it out there. So what did the
trumpet and shirt, what? Rhythmic device,
triplets, Jacobi feed, bop, bop,
bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
So the focusing on rhythm can tell
us a lot about the detail, uh,
going on in pop music or in classical
music in particular. I'd like to end,
I think I have a few minutes here.
I'd like to end with a particular piece.
We were talking about Mozart before,
and we're going to go on now
to talk about Mozart's requiem.
It's a requiem mass. What's a mash?
Well, a mass is a genre of music.
Obviously it's a religious service as
well, but it says genre of music like the,
where they can share it though. Bach
wrote a mass, Mozart wrote many masses.
Beethoven wrote two
important masses and so on.
So it's a genre of music.
The requiem mass is a particular
kind of mass. It's a mass,
obviously for a death and burial.
And the commemorates of
those who have died. Uh,
unlike the regular mass,
the requiem mass has a very special
movement associated with it.
It's called the DA's earring. The
day of Wrath. It's just a long,
long texts that set to music.
But that text has V is
drawn from apocalypse,
the images of apocalypse.
And have you ever read
the book of Apocalypse or
revelation? You know, it's hell.
Fire and brimstone, the
Day of judgment, damnation,
election into the group
of the blessing and so on.
So it's a very vivid kind of text,
very vivid kind of texts.
Now I was going to put that text up on
the board. And to be honest with you,
I forgot to do that. So I'm going to
have to see if I can remember this text.
But here's the tea.
We're going to focus now on
the two sections of this work.
The conflict totties and
the lock Cremosa Dh Ila,
they are both subsets of the DAC ray,
the confluent totties,
uh,
go the Texas follows Kung
Fu totties melodic t's,
woke out and welcome a
coon Benny deek teas.
So on one side here we've got
the totties melodic [inaudible].
These are the downed on the other side,
we've got WOCA welcome a call me,
call me coon. Benedictus. These are the,
the blessing. Okay. Ever
been to a medieval cathedral.
You walk in the front door,
Christ in majesty on the left side of
the damned writhing and on the right side
are the blessed that looking at good deal,
happier.
So most of them may have had this image
in mind of the damned and the elect,
but he sure was able to set it this
text through music by using a couple of
devices. The first of these is
rhythmic. So we're going to turn now,
I guess we'll turn off the lights and
we're going to go to a couple of slides
here.
Let's take a look at the rhythm
he associates with the dam.
Uh, what kind of rhythm do we get
with the day? Well, we're going to,
where would you expect to find the damn
in the high register? The low registers,
the lower registers, they're way down
29th Canto of hell or somewhere. Uh,
so here's what we find
and as you can see there,
is this bass rhythm moving slowly or,
or quickly?
Very quickly it's going like this.
[inaudible] so
it's also doing what?
Going up or down? Up.
It keeps rising up. This
builds tension. Okay.
Are these folk singing there where
they've got this kind of music? Yeah.
Is this called joke music? Step
wise music or jumpy? Skippy music.
Pretty skippy.
Is it constant music or Disney music?
Very dissonant as it major or minor.
Cause you'd get about four things.
He's working with your,
but rhythm is very important.
Now eventually the elect to
come here and their rhythm.
What do they have? Are they high
or low? Well, they're way up high.
You can see them in the sopranos and
Altos up there and they just sit there on
that pitch.
A long note,
I don't have the next page.
That's what they do. It's
consonant, it's in major,
it's high and most important.
The rhythm is very uncomplicated.
The notes are long and slow.
So let's listen to Mozart's
depiction of Hell and heaven here.
[inaudible]
to hill and then back. It goes back and
forth to rhythmically very different,
uh, concepts. Now,
Mozart died in December, 1791 he
wasn't planning on dying. Actually,
his death came rather suddenly and he
was working on a requiem that someone had
commissioned from him under
rather mysterious circumstances.
And he began to think of it as well
as his own requiem. Uh, indeed,
he didn't actually finish it up. Brian,
if I could have the next slide please.
Here from the Austrian National
Library where I was, uh,
last summer photographing and having a
wonderful time is the last page of the
Mozart Mozart ever wrote here.
This is the locking Molson's sort of
breaking off and he doesn't finish this
particular movement. It's the last
movement that he was working on,
but he has a student, their fronts
Havi sue smile and sue smile, uh,
was given instructions and probably
sketch pages as well as to how to finish
this. So Mozart was able to finish it
and it looks, or, excuse me, excuse my,
was able to finish it and it looks
like this. Next slide please.
Prime here we have a score of it,
of the peace.
And there just a couple of details
that I want to point out here.
It begins with what I always hear
is a kind of funeral cortege idea.
Of course it's in minor and the voices
will come in, but the base is going
sort of plodding along and a baked sick
Dupo but with a triple subdivision under
neath of that.
And then at the words you can see,
well maybe you can't see, but the text
is on that terrible sorrowful day.
We have the words,
where is it [inaudible] x Favi Law
on which research it will come forth
research. It will come up out
of the ashes, homo ratios,
the just person to be judged,
the just person to be judged.
And notice how it's like the coffins
opening up and here comes Mozart's soprano
line.
Wow. What a run. But it's all
kind of texts depiction here.
And then in the next page he's going to
take that same rising line and assign it
to the basis.
Um,
let's go on Brian to the next slide
and then we're going to go back.
Then we have the change of text here,
who week air goal parched a days,
therefore save God parquet imperative
savers p a zoo yeas who dominate.
And at that text what he does
is shift from this dark minor.
And you can write on the words
the age too. He's already
mm,
sweet, Major. And then he'll
work his way back, right?
The minor.
As the funeral cortege continues and this
time the line will go down instead of
rising up. So this goes
on for a while. Uh, Brian,
if we could go back to the previous slide,
we're going to start,
we're going to listen
to the entire movement.
It runs about a barely a four minutes.
So bear with me here.
Will run about 30 seconds over
as we listened to the, uh,
lock Cremosa out of the DAC,
right as the requiem mass of Wolfgang
Amadeus Mozart written in Vienna,
1791.
Nice and loud.
Yeah.
Uh,
[inaudible] hey Courtney.
Now the basis
quiet prayer
change to
major
and the modulation change of key for
major to back to minor as the Cortez and
start up again. Next slide, right.
Nice clarinet sound there.
Here comes our core with the base
[inaudible].
Hello?
So that's the last music of Wolfgang
Amadeus Mozart and his pupil.
So smile and a little bit not
to leave you in a somber mood.
Let's listen to Louis Armstrong's,
we'd go out dancing to happen.